.
>> WELL, GOOD EVENING.
WELL TO A SPECIAL EDITION OF
"TUCKER CARLSON TONIGHT."
EVERYBODY IS FOCUSED ON THE
MID-TERMS FOR GOOD REASON.
BIGGER ELECTIONS HAVE ALREADY
HAPPENED.
THESE WERE LOCAL RACES THAT YOU
PROBABLY HAVEN'T HEARD ABOUT
BECAUSE NOBODY PAYS ATTENTION.
LAST WEEK THE REPUBLICAN PARTY
FLIPPED FIVE MAJORITY LEFT
DISTRICTS IN FLORIDA.
MIAMI-DADE, DUVAL, MARTIN AND
CLAY COUNTYS.
MIAMI-DADE IS ONE OF THE BIGGEST
SCHOOL DISTRICTS IN THE ENTIRE
COUNTRY.
IT HAS MORE THAN 300,000
STUDENTS IN IT.
THIS CHANGE HAS MAJOR
IMPLICATIONS FOR THE EDUCATION
IN THE FUTURE OF MILLIONS OF
YOUNG PEOPLE.
IT'S NOT JUST HAPPENING IN
FLORIDA.
A TEXAS SCHOOL BOARD THAT
FLIPPED TO THE REPUBLICAN PARTY
EARLIER THIS YEAR IS ALREADY
WORKING TO CHANGE THINGS.
THEY VOTED TO BAN RACE, HATRED
AND GENDER CULT IDEOLOGIES IN
SCHOOLS.
LET'S SAY YOU'RE A REPUBLICAN
RUNNING FOR CONGRESS.
YOU MIGHT BE WONDER HOW DID
THESE REPUBLICANS WIN AT THE
LOCAL LEVEL.
IT'S NOT JUST BECAUSE IT'S A RED
WAVE YEAR.
ACTUALLY IT'S NOT A RED WAVE
YEAR SO FAR DESPITE WHAT YOU MAY
HAVE HEARD.
IN OTHER RACES SO FAR, SPECIAL
ELECTIONS, REPUBLICANS HAVE BEEN
UNDERPERFORMING AMAZINGLY.
FOR EXAMPLE IN A SPECIAL
ELECTION LAST WEEK, PAT RYAN WON
IN NEW YORK.
IN A RED WAVE YEAR, YOU WOULD
HAVE THOUGHT THE OPPOSITE YEAR
WOULD HAPPEN, THIS IS A TIGHT
DISTRICT.
THIS DISTRICT WENT TO JOE BIDEN
BY EIGHT POINTS.
THAT'S NOT A HUGE MARGIN.
DEMOCRATS WON ANYWAY DESPITE JOE
BIDEN'S APPROVAL NUMBERS HAVE
DROPPED.
DEMOCRATIC CANDIDATES ACROSS THE
COUNTRY HAVE BEEN OUTPERFORMING
JOE BIDEN'S 2020 NUMBERS IN
THREE OTHER HOUSE SPECIAL
ELECTIONS.
ELECTIONS IN NEBRASKA, MINNESOTA
AND THE 23rd DISTRICT OF
NEW YORK.
SO WHY IS THE QUESTION?
HOW COULD THIS BE HAPPENING?
THE DEMOCRATIC PARTY HAS A
SIMPLY EXPLANATION.
ABORTION.
DEMOCRATIC VOTERS ARE MAD ABOUT
ROE V. WADE BEING APPEALED AND
THEY'RE VOTING IN BIG NUMBERS.
THERE'S EVIDENCE THAT THE
REPUBLICAN PARTY MAY BE AT FAULT
BY ALIENATING ITS OWN VOTERS.
NOT GETTING THEM TO THE POLLS.
RYAN HAS DONE A LOT OF WORK ON
THIS.
HE RUNS THE 1776 PROJECT PACT.
HE SUPPORTED THE SCHOOL BOARD
CANDIDATES.
HE WROTE THAT THE REPUBLICANS
ARE UNDERPERFORMING THIS YEAR
BECAUSE TURNOUT IN RURAL
COUNTIES IS ABOUT 30% OF WHAT IT
WAS IN 2018, THE MID-TERM THAT
YEAR.
CITIES AND SUBURBS, DEMOCRATIC
STRONG HOLDS, HAD DOUBLED THAT
LEVEL OF TURNOUT.
SO WHY ARE REPUBLICANS WINNING
IN SCHOOL BOARD RACES IN FLOOR
AND LOSING IN OTHER RACES THEY
SHOULD BE WIN SOMETHING THE
ANSWER MIGHT LIE WITH THE
CANDIDATES AND WHAT THEY'RE
TALKING ABOUT.
FOR EXAMPLE, IN FEBRUARY, MARK
MULINARO, THE GUY THAT SHOULD
HAVE WON IN NEW YORK, TOLD THE
COUNTY OFFICE BUILDING TO
ILLUMINATE THE BUILDING IN RED
AND BLUE.
THOSE ARE NOT THE COUNTY COLORS.
THEY'RE UKRAINE'S COLORS.
AS IF HIS VOTERS CARE.
THAT'S THE MESSAGE THAT HIS
EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR OF DUCHESS
COUNTY NEW YORK SENT TO VOTERS.
POUGHKEEPSIE STANDS WITH
UKRAINE.
RIGHT.
EVERYBODY IS SYMPATHETIC TO
UKRAINE, BUT IS THAT THE MAIN
ISSUE?
IT'S A JOKE.
THE SAME CANDIDATE SENT
FUND-RAISING E-MAILS CALLING FOR
MORE AGGRESSION AGAINST RUSSIA.
BIDEN IS WEAK ON PUTIN, HE
WROTE.
RIGHT.
SO JUST SOUNDING LIKE LINDSEY
GRAHAM WORK?
OUR VOTERS ARE RACIST BUT
UKRAINE'S BOARDERS ARE NOT.
>> THE QUESTION IS CAN WE DO
MORE AND SHOULD WE DO MORE.
THE ANSWER IS YES TO BOTH.
AS TO MY FRIENDS IN THE
PENTAGON, YOU TOLD ALL OF US
THAT THIS WAR WOULD LAST THREE
OR FOUR DAYS.
THAT KYIV WOULD FALL.
THAT, YOU KNOW, THE COUNTRY
WOULD BE OVERWHELMED BY THE
RUSSIAN MILITARY.
THEY'RE WRONG.
SO QUITE FRANKLY, I TRUST
PRESIDENT ZELENSKY'S JUDGMENT
ABOUT WHAT WOULD HELP HIM IN
REAL TIME MORE THAN ANYBODY ELSE
ON THE PLANET RIGHT NOW.
>> Tucker: OKAY.
JUST TO BE CLEAR TO REPUBLICAN
CANDIDATES, THAT WAS LINDSEY
GRAHAM, YOUR JOB IS TO MAKE FUN
OF LINDSEY GRAHAM AND TO DISAVOW
HIM.
YOUR JOB IS NOT TO EMULATE
LINDSEY GRAHAM AND STEAL HIS
TALKING POINTS.
IF YOU DO EMULATE LINDSEY GRAHAM
AND STEAL HIS TALKING POINTS,
YOU WILL LOSE.
THE LOSING CANDIDATES DID JUST
THAT.
SO COMPARE WHAT THEY WERE SAYING
TO WHAT, FOR EXAMPLE, JOE KENT
WAS SAYING IN WASHINGTON STATE
WHEN HE WON HIS PRIMARY THERE AS
A CHALLENGER.
WATCH THIS.
>> IF ANY OF THESE
REPRESENTATIVES FEEL SO
PASSIONATELY ABOUT HOW WE HAVE
TO SAVE THE UKRAINIANS ABOUT
PROVIDE AID AND CONTINUE TO PUSH
THIS ESCALATION, THEY NEED TO GO
BACK TO THEIR DISTRICTS AND TELL
THEIR CONSTITUENTS WHAT THEY'RE
ASKING THEM TO DO AND WHAT THE
RAMIFICATIONS POTENTIALLY COULD
BE.
WHY DO FOREIGN NATIONS ALWAYS
COME FIRST.
WE DO WE SECURE THEIR BORDERS
AND NOT OUR OWN.
>> Tucker: EXACTLY.
NOTHING AGAINST THE UKRAINIANS.
EVERYONE FEELS SORRY FOR THEM.
BUT AMERICANS HAVE A RIGHT TO
FEEL SAD ABOUT WHAT'S GOING ON
IN THEIR COUNTRY AND EXPECT
THEIR POLITICIANS TO WORK ON
FIXING IT.
SO IF MORE REPUBLICANS IN
NOVEMBER SAY WHAT YOU JUST HEARD
JOE KENT SAY, THEY WILL WIN.
IF THEY TALK ABOUT ISSUES THAT
PEOPLE CARE ABOUT IN THIS
COUNTRY, ISSUES RELEVANT TO
THEIR LIVES, THEY WILL WIN.
THAT'S HOW THEY WON THE SCHOOL
BOARD SEATS IN FLORIDA.
THEY WEREN'T TALKING ABOUT
UKRAINE.
THEY TALKED ABOUT THE ISSUES
THAT MATTER.
FAMILY, SAFETY, HAPPINESS, THE
RIGHT OF PARENTS TO DECIDE WHAT
THEIR KIDS LEARN IN SCHOOL.
THAT MESSAGE WINS.
OBVIOUSLY.
THAT'S WHY GLENN YOUNGKIN BECAME
GOVERNOR OF VIRGINIA.
>> WE'RE GOING TO EMBRACE OUR
PARENTS, NOT IGNORE THEM.
WE'RE GOING TO PRESS FORWARD
WITH A CURRICULUM THAT INCLUDES
LISTENING TO PARENTS INPUT, A
CURRICULUM THAT ALLOWS OUR
CHILDREN TO RUN AS FAST AS THEY
CAN, TEACHING THEM HOW TO THINK
AND ENABLING THEIR DREAMS TO
SOAR.
FRIENDS, WE'RE GOING TO
RE-ESTABLISH EXCELLENCE IN OUR
SCHOOLS.
>> Tucker: THAT WAS GLENN
YOUNGKIN'S MESSAGE.
YOU'RE A PARENT.
SCHOOLS EXIST FOR YOUR CHILDREN.
THEY'RE YOUR CHILDREN.
THEY DON'T BELONG TO THE
TEACHER'S UNION.
WE'RE GOING TO LISTEN TO YOU.
TERRY McAULIFFE WAS RUNNING
AGAINST GLENN YOUNGKIN.
HE HAD THE ADVANTAGE OF A LOT OF
MONEY.
HERE'S HIS MESSAGE.
I DON'T THINK PARENTS SHOULD BE
TELLING SCHOOLS WHAT THEY CAN
TEACH.
OH!
TURNS OUT MOST PEOPLE DISAGREE
AND HE WAS DESTROYED.
HIS POLITICAL CAREER HIT THE
BRICK WALL IT LONG DESERVED.
SO TURNS OUT THE REPUBLICANS
THAT FOCUS ON THE THINGS THAT
MATTER, FAMILIES, PROTECTING
FAMILIES WILL WIN.
ALONG WITH THE 1776 PROJECT, RON
DESANTIS IS ONE OF THE BIGGEST
SUPPORTERS OF THE SCHOOL BOARD
CANDIDATES.
THIS WEEK DESANTIS SIGNED A LAW
BANNING TEACHERS TO TALK ABOUT
SEX WITH YOUR KINDERGARTENERS.
IT'S CREEPY AND SHOULD BE
ILLEGAL.
DESANTIS ALSO FIRED A PROSECUTOR
THAT REFUSED TO ENFORCE THE LAW.
>> THE PROSECUTOR, STATE
ATTORNEY FOR THIS JUDICIAL
CIRCUI
CIRCUIT, ANDREW WARREN HAS PUT
HIMSELF PUBLICLY ABOVE THE LAW.
IN JUNE OF 2021, HE SIGNED A
LETTER SAYING THAT HE WOULD NOT
ENFORCE ANY PROHIBITIONS ON SEX
CHANGE OPERATIONS FOR MINORS.
MOST RECENTLY AFTER THE DOBBS
DECISION WAS RENDERED BY THE
U.S. SUPREME COURT, HE SIGNED A
LETTER SAYING HE WOULD NOT
ENFORCE ANY LAWS RELATING TO
PROTECTING THE RIGHT TO LIFE IN
THE STATE OF FLORIDA.
MIND YOU, WE'VE HAD PROHIBITION
ON THIRD TRIMESTER ABORTIONS FOR
A LONG TIME.
WHEN YOU MAKE YOURSELF ABOVE THE
LAW, YOU HAVE VIOLATED YOUR
DUTY, NEGLECTED YOUR DUTY AND
DISPLAYING A LACK OF COMPETENCE
TO PERFORM THOSE DUTIES.
TODAY WE'RE SUSPENDING STATE
ATTORNEY ANDREW WARREN
EFFECTIVELY IMMEDIATELY.
>> Tucker: SO ENFORCE THE LAW.
THAT'S A WINNING MESSAGE, TOO.
IT'S ABOUT ENDING THE
LAWLESSNESS THAT MAKES IT
IMPOSSIBLE FOR AMERICANS TO LIVE
IN THEIR OWN CITIES.
BLAKE MASTERS CAUGHT ON TO THAT
MESSAGE.
THAT'S HOW HE WON IN ARIZONA.
>> WE CAN NEVER AMNESTY ANY
ILLEGAL ALIEN, PERIOD.
IF YOUR FIRST INTERACTION WITH
OUR COUNTRY IS TO BREAK
IMMIGRATION LAWS, YOU WILL NEVER
GET AMNESTY, YOU WILL NEVER
BECOME A UNITED STATES CITIZEN.
THAT'S A LINE IN THE SAND.
WE WON'T CROSS IT.
WE HAVE TO STOP INCENTIVIZING
ILLEGAL IMMIGRATION.
IF YOU'RE NOT DEPORTING PORT,
YOU DON'T HAVE SECURITY.
>> Tucker: WHAT IS WRONG WITH
THAT?
HOW CAN YOU IGNORE THE OWN LAWS
THAT YOUR REPRESENTATIVES PASS?
IT'S CHAOS AND LAWLESSNESS.
NOW THEY'RE CALLING FOR GUN
CONFISCATION.
GUNS FROM LAW-ABIDING CITIZENS
THAT WOULD MAKE YOU AS RELIANT
ON POSSIBLE OR POLICE FORCES
THAT ARE UNDERFUNDED.
HOW UNDERFUNDED?
HAVE YOU CHECKED THE RESPONSE
TIMES IN YOUR CITY RECENTLY?
IN NEW ORLEANS, THE POLICE
RESPONSE TIME IS OVER TWO HOURS.
LONG ENOUGH FOR YOU TO GET
KILLED.
THE CITY IS TALKING ABOUT
CANCELLING MARDI GRAS BECAUSE
THEY HAVE NO COPS.
IN SEATTLE, THE CITY COUNCIL
JUST REPORTED AVERAGE AND MEDIAN
RESPONSE TIMES UP IN EVERY
PRESENT WHEN COMPARED TO THE
LAST FOUR YEARS OF DATA.
OKAY.
IN AUSTIN TEXAS, THE MOST
RESPONSE TIMES ARE DRAMATICALLY
SLOWER.
IT'S A HUGE PROBLEM.
AND PUTS SELF-PROTECTION ON THE
INDIVIDUAL.
YOU HAVE TO PROTECT YOUR OWN
FAMILY.
IT'S ALWAYS BEEN YOUR RIGHT.
NOW IT'S YOUR OBLIGATION.
ARE REPUBLICANS RECOGNIZE
THIS?
HERE'S JOHN CORNYN CALLING FOR
GUN CONFISCATION SO YOU CAN'T
PROTECT YOURSELF WHEN THE COPS
DON'T SHOW UP.
>> I DON'T WANT US TO PASS A
BILL FOR THE PURPOSE OF CHECKING
A BOX.
I WANT TO MAKE SURE THAT WE DO
SOMETHING USEFUL.
SOMETHING THAT IS CAPABLE OF
BECOMING A LAW.
SOMETHING THAT WILL HAVE THE
POTENTIAL TO SAVE LIVES.
I'M HAPPY TO REPORT AS A RESULT
OF THE HARD WORK OF A NUMBER OF
SENATORS IN THIS CHAMBER THAT WE
HAVE MADE SOME SERIOUS PROGRESS.
SO SOON, VERY SOON, NOT SOON
ENOUGH FOR ME, BUT VERY SOON, WE
WILL SEE THE TEXT OF BIPARTISAN
LEGISLATION THAT WILL HELP KEEP
OUR CHILDREN AND OUR COMMUNITIES
SAFER.
>> Tucker: IT WON'T SAVE A
SINGLE CHILD.
HE KNOWS THAT.
IT WILL TAKE FIREARMS AWAY FROM
THE LAW-ABIDING WHILE THEY
REMAIN IN THE HANDS OF THE LAW
BREAKING.
IT WILL MAKE THE COUNTRY MORE
DANGEROUS.
THAT'S A REPUBLICAN UNITED
STATES SENATOR WHO IS NOT UP FOR
ELECTION BUT WILL BE PUNISHED
FOR WHAT HE DID.
THE POINT IS THE REPUBLICAN
PARTY IN WASHINGTON SEEMS TO
HAVE MISSED ALL OF THIS.
LOOK AT THE ELECTIONS TAKES
PLACE ALREADY THIS YEAR, THE
CLEAREST POSSIBLE SIGN, THE
POSSIBLE THAT RUN THE REPUBLICAN
PARTY STOP TALKING ABOUT
UKRAINE, STOP TAKING PEOPLE'S
GUNS AWAY AND START TALKING
ABOUT THINGS THAT THEY CARE
ABOUT.
THE ECONOMY, EDUCATION, FAMILY,
SAFETY, JUSTICE, FOLLOWING THE